Okay. Everybody. Thank you
guys so much for coming.
We really appreciate you guys coming
out with an awesome talk for you guys.
We have Ben, you simmer.
Mom got over here and, uh,
I'd love to kind of introduce them.
So, uh, Ben, uh, once a Harvard,
he actually dropped out to become a teal
fellow. Uh, 2013, he got into crypto. Uh,
he turned 15 k into what
is now over $1 million. Uh,
he wrote the crypto one on one post on
medium, which is great kind of primer.
If you're not familiar with crypto.
It's a great kind of intro introductory,
just a overview of the space.
Uh,
and so I sent it to a lot of my
friends if they're, you know,
they're not really familiar.
Um,
he actually became a kind of an
internet celebrity in his own right. Uh,
so we got over 50 million Facebook views
on his videos and he realized that he
just didn't profit a
dime off of those videos.
And so he realized that there
was kind of a problem. Uh,
and so he decided to create stream,
which kind of disintermediation, uh,
the creators and the audience,
um,
and allows creators to kind of profit
more and engage more authentically, uh,
with their audience without being
beholden to kind of outside interests. Uh,
so simmer is the other
cofounder of stream. Uh,
he graduated from Stanford where
he studied AI and bio computation.
He built one of the top
14 apps in the APP store,
which gained him recognition from both
the White House and the Department of
Education.
Um,
and he built one of the first Ios apps
to do realtime video classification.
So I already touched on what stream does
it disintermediate content creators and,
uh,
and,
and the audience and allows kind of
creators to engage more authentically, uh,
you know, without being beholden to
outside interests. And, uh, yeah.
Without further ado,
I'll give it up for team stream.
Yeah. First off, I just want to
knowledge thank you guys so much for
being here. I know this is lunch time.
Like really appreciate you guys all
coming out and supporting us. Um,
and just listen to what we
have to say. It's always, uh,
it's always definitely a bucket list
side of it's always been on my list.
So thank you so much for bringing us
here and giving us the chance to talk to
you guys. Um, so really quickly,
you know, I think Bitcoin, right?
There's a lot of, if you guys
been falling recently, um,
and this is just like a quick story.
All the rage.
I was literally at Thanksgiving,
this pit. So this pat, you know,
this past Thursday, um, and I was sitting
at the dinner table and my uncles,
my cousins, literally, everybody's
like, how do I get into bitcoin?
Then you hours in crypto. And they
were like, Whoa, like I want to buy.
Like it was like a news. It
was show interesting to kind
of see the energy there.
Cool.
So real quick also I want to give you a
quick background of how everyone is in
this room, right? So raise your pans.
You guys have no exposure to crypto.
You guys want just like
a full introduction.
The only one here who just like it doesn't
know anything about crypto. All right.
How many of you guys actually feel
like you are pretty proficient.
You understand what bitcoin is, how it
works, talking, glue, all those things.
Raise your hands. All right,
cool. Awesome. Awesome.
That's somewhere between
that, right? This is perfect.
That's exactly what the song is. So
awesome. That works all sure. Okay.
So just really quick and you're
going back to the, to the story show.
She comes up to me, she's like, I want
to buy bitcoin. That I was like, okay,
this is, I feel like he's like a
teaching moment. And so I went,
I've got a piece of paper and it was like,
let's make your own coin. Right. And we,
we called it, we called it and Sarah
coin because it was her name. Um,
and it was like, okay, go and see if you
can actually get something from this,
right? You have this piece of
paper, this is your Sarah coin.
Let's see what you can do.
Right. And she went and she got,
she actually like ended up getting like,
she's got an extra slice of Pumpkin
pie by the end of the day. Um,
one thing that's really
interesting and that was,
that was for me like one thing
that's really interesting,
it's like this idea of what
really is money, right?
Like when we think about these coins,
like what does,
what constitutes value in a specific
currency, right? Um, and I think that's,
you know, a lot of we're going
to be touching on today, um,
specifically within our talk is thinking
about what is the history of money in
Bitcoin? How does it actually fit
in? How have we created this? Right?
A lot of people think it's a scam,
it's fake money. Like all this,
like how do we actually think about
this and actually diving in some of the
fundamentals then actually thinking about,
okay,
what are these next layers of technology
smart contract disintermediation,
what does that look like? And then
finally we'll kind of close out with,
I know there's a lot of new
crypto projects coming out,
some of our thoughts on crypto economics.
Where does that actually have space right
in the current ecosystem and what are
the value propositions there by actually
taking a case study through stream?
The project that me and
Ben are both working on.
So at that I'll let Ben kind of
take it away with who had some,
a lot of the history of money, uh, in
boy. Yeah. You mind if I grab the clicker,
go for it. Awesome. Sooner. I'm
going to walk through all those,
but also I want to make sure that you
guys are giving the value that you want to
own this. So at any point, you know,
I'm going to stop and have questions
between instruction and then you guys tell
us up. You know, that's
exciting. That's interesting.
Or if you want to dive in to
somebody else. So real quick,
I think it's important to us take bitcoin
in the context of where it came from.
Right?
And what was the motivation behind it.
And there's very clearly motivated
by the 2008 financial crisis.
So the bitcoin white paper came out
immediately basically after this happens.
And you could see those,
a straw moving factor because in the
first bitcoin transaction that actually,
and I had a headline
from Mica UK newspaper,
whereas like banks are on the brink of
bail out right from governments and so
will happen in 2008 well it's super
interesting because we had a lot of things
that contributed to the financial crisis
and I'm sure you guys are all aware,
right?
The great recession occurred and why have
recurred specifically was because of a
lot of the parts of the
mind, sorry, system today.
So one of the first main parts of how
money works say is fractional reserve
banking.
So real show of hands is anyone Miller?
Warren fractional reserve
banking is, okay. Awesome. Great.
So I'll explain this from scratch.
So one story short,
when you give $1,000 to bank today,
they are legally allowed to go out and
spend up to $900 about money, right?
So they have a requirement that they
have a reserve that they have to keep up
customer deposits.
And that's about 10% so when you
give a bank $100 million right?
They only have to keep
$10 million on hand.
What that leads to our two main problems,
like it happened, right? In most cases,
this is totally fine because if you trust
your bank, you're not going to go out.
You're not going to
take all your money out.
Very rarely do people take more than 10%
of the deposits at one time out of the
bank, right? And only when
that number is reached,
are there any problems? So 90% of
the time, everything's totally fine,
but when people do start to have a panic
or people wanting to take their money
out, or there's some sort of a issue
that they're seeing in the system,
it can collapse very quickly, right?
So you have a liquidity crunch.
So if more than 10% of people
want to take their money out,
then the bank is like, all right,
we can't give you money. Right?
And that's when things start
spiraling in a really bad way,
because that leads to more panic,
right?
And you have this vicious cycle where
more people are trying to take money out.
That's not quite exactly what happened.
2008. That's what happened in say,
the Great Depression,
right?
You have this phenomenon knows as bank
run where all you see these like lines
rather people just outside the
bank trying to get their money.
And that's because the bank
doesn't have your money anymore.
And the other aspect of this that's
really bad though is when they spend your
money, they put it into investments,
right? They're trying to,
they're basically taking your money and
like earning money with your money and
they can do this poorly.
So what actually happened,
2008 was we had the
subprime mortgage crisis.
So they put money in these highly
inflated mortgages that were being,
uh, lends out to all these people who
couldn't really pay it back, right?
So then we have this huge problem where
they lost a lot of this money or now
they're left holding these
assets in foreclosure,
which are just worth way less in reality.
Then they were on paper.
And then so the whole system
basically start glossy.
And so the government after the
great depression was like, holy crap,
this is really bad. Because in the Great
Depression, all the banks failed, right?
And so they created this
thing called the FDAC, right?
The Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation.
So you guys are probably familiar,
you know, right now, if
you put your money in bank,
it says $250,000 are insured by the FTC.
And this gives you some of New Year of
like safety. It's like, oh, don't worry.
It's fine if the bank goes down,
the government's got your bag. Well,
the unfortunate thing is the FTC has
actually justice underfunded as banks,
in fact,
more so,
they are legally only required to keep
1% of all customer deposits that they
insure on hands.
So if you can see here f more than
1% of bank deposits are defaulted on.
They actually don't have
the money to save the day.
And so this isn't just a hypothetical,
it's actually happened before.
There's a thing called the savings and
loan crisis back in the 1980s and so in
rapid succession, and again,
things are almost always fine,
but when they go bad, they go bad very
quickly and very Kasra optically, right?
It's a brittle system,
right? So everything's okay,
but when it breaks a showers and so in
the savings and loan crisis of 1980s out
thousand banks, out of the 3,200 of these
bags that are called like saving space,
right? They felled in rapid succession
and there's actually sister insurance
corporation to the see that was the
federal like savings and loans, uh,
insurance corporation. And that
immediately was like, holy crap,
we don't have the money to like save
a fraction of these banks. Right?
So they actually had to be recapitalized
again and again with taxpayer money,
which is exactly the same thing
we saw happen, say 2008, right?
Where the government's basically at the
expense of taxpayers saved all these
banks and bailed them out.
And in fact,
even with all these bailouts of
the governments gave f a F, s,
l, I, C or whatever it's called. Um, yeah,
they gave up after only fixing
after basically recovering
about 300 of the banks
out of the 1000 films there. I got
there. I'm good. Cool. Keep it.
They actually dissolved themselves.
Right?
And so we've actually seen this happen
in practice. So the FDI see again,
very poorly capitalized, just like
normal. A normal banks are too.
So not that much safety.
And then this problem is actually
compounded by Fiat currency.
So this goes back to the idea of
like what exactly is money, right?
And money today,
as we know it is generally a currency
that's issued and controlled entirely by
government and backed by nothing
but faith and that government.
So in the past we used to have these
things called say gold standards, right?
And that's something that's pretty easy.
It's to understand that it's like at the,
you have a dollar,
you could redeem it for a
certain amount of gold, right?
And so you always knew that your dollar
had value because it was backed by gold.
Now since the 1970s since
the Nixon Nixon shock,
we actually have currencies
are completely free flowing,
darn backed by anything but
trust in the government.
And so this is extremely interesting
because what it means is that if you
actually look through the test of time,
no Fiat currency is actually ever
survived a long enough time scale.
And the reason for that is because you
always have a central point of failure
and the government.
So as long as you trust your government
to be very responsible for your money
throughout its entire history,
then everything's fine,
right? It's totally great.
But that's a, that's a bigF , right?
And in most cases actually you can't
actually trust the government to always be
perfect all the way through, right? And
so they can do a lot of different things.
You know, quantitive quantitative easing
happens now we have, you know, every four,
eight years new president comes in,
right? They change economic policy.
And so you're privy to all these things
that you don't really have that much
agency over but have a huge potential
impact on you. And so we can see this,
some classic examples. For example,
our Zimbabwe, everyone mostly knows,
I guess about what happened there.
This is the classic example of
what hyper inflation can do.
And you can actually see it like really
spirals out in this crazy way over time,
right? So just in a matter of months, it's
like, all right, it's getting pretty bad.
You know, like, uh, your
money's not really worth that
much anymore. And it's like,
all right, things seem like maybe they're
okay, but holy crap, now it's really bad.
And so like at the end of this thing,
right,
it's like you would be in the grocery
store and by the time you entered the
grocery store and by the time you left,
like your money would have like doubled
in like a, it's diluted the value.
And so they ultimately collapsed.
But that is not just,
people think that that's the
domain of just like, you know,
these really third party governments
are really poor. Actually,
it's true right now,
today in Venezuela as well.
But even with the u s when the u s
first started, few people know this.
We create a currency called continental
back in 1775 and within three years of
lost 80% of its value within 13 years
in hyperinflated so much that they
actually had to completely
abandon constant downsell
currency and issue an edict
that you can only have currency that
was backed by gold or silver because why
would anyone trust the US government?
Right? And so it's interesting in that.
So let's move,
uh,
it's a good segue into basically gold
and why gold has held its value as a
calorie points, a Fiat currencies
well over 5,000 years plus.
So there's record this and people using
gold as a store value since 3000 BC
today, it's still holds its value, in
fact, intelligence value pretty, uh,
well over that entire 5,000 years and
no Fiat currency has ever come close to
that.
So let's explore why that's the case
because it's a good analog to what bitcoin
has this value as its value proposition.
Because bitcoin was actually designed
essentially at one form as a better form
of a gold. So gold has value because
there is no central point of failure.
It's trustless and that you don't have
to depend on the bank or you know,
a central bank or government to
issue gold, you know that. No,
so the problem with a Fiat
currency again is that, um,
the central bank can issue
money on demand, right?
And so when you create new money,
you have flaked the money supply,
but you don't actually change the economy.
So the economy is say,
$100 million and you have $100,000
discount, $100 million, then you know,
um, that's if someone
prints twice as much money,
you're basically diluting everyone
who holds us dollar say, right?
You're having the money supplied.
And so actually in practice we have a
designed inflation rate of an average
about two to 3% every year.
And that doesn't seem like too much.
But compound interest means a about
every 20 years your money halves in real
buying power.
So if you have $100 today,
it's actually getting by basically
$50 worth of things in 20 years.
And so gold solves this problem
because it's inherently scarce.
You know that there's no central bank
that could at any point just make more
money. And so because of that,
people will put a lot faith and gold.
And also there's no one part
that you have to trust. And um,
let's see.
There are some caveats of goal too though,
and that we think that it's scarce.
We think that production
can actually increase,
but actually you can because
it's not future proof.
What I mean by future proof
is we've gotten a lot better
and a lot of technology,
right? And part of that technology that
we've gotten better at is mining gold.
So you can actually see here
in the last a hundred years,
our gold production has
about a quadrupled, right?
And so we used to do about 705 tons of
gold production back in 1912. Now in 2014,
we do 2,880.
And that's because it's a lot easier
to my goal today then it was a hundred
years ago.
It's way easier to mind goal today than
it was back in like Roman times. Right?
And so we have this false
sense of the supply is scarce,
but it's actually not that scarce.
And in fact,
half of all the gold as ever been mined
in history has been mined in the last 50
years.
So this is like a pretty wild thing.
And like there are other things
that can happen too. For example,
someone could spontaneously finds a
huge cache of gold in California spark a
gold rush. And so there were all these
things up. While it seems scarce,
it's not quite predictable
and that's important.
And so let's compare this with bitcoin.
Let's walk into why bitcoin has value
in the world today as a store of money,
right?
And so bitcoin that like gold is
valuable because it is inherently scarce,
but more so than that it's
also inherently predictable.
And so this is extremely important because
in order to be able to really value
your money over time, and you have to know
that you know how much money there is,
right?
You have to know that the money supply
is going to be a predictable increase.
And then from that you can understand,
you know,
how the economy is going to function.
So here we can actually say this is how
gold production has worked over time,
where bitcoin production
has worked over time,
where at the very beginning of time we
used to every 10 minutes on average about
50 big ones. And then over time
the House that goes to 25 bitcoins,
12.5 6.5 3.15 and so forth
until it finally evens out
that I'm 21 total million
bitcoins. So you can compare
these two lines, right?
This is how gold production
works every time.
This is how bitcoin
production works over time.
And the reality of bitcoin production
follows this curve. Exactly. Basically.
And so how does this exactly work?
And um,
feel free to jump into this if you want,
but um, yeah, basically long story short,
Bitcoin was designed to be future proof
because it's governed just by code,
right? And what we mean by that
is it is dictated that on average,
one bitcoin that's going to be found
every 10 minutes or one on one block is
going to be found every 10 minutes.
And in that block there's a coin base
transaction in initial transaction that
rewards this new 50 bitcoins are
25 bitcoins to 12.5 bitcoins.
So how exactly does that work? Well,
basically in order to mine Bitcoin,
I'm sure you guys have heard of
this term of mining bitcoin, right?
It's an analog to
basically gold production,
but in southern mining
it out of the ground,
you're now mining it with a computer.
How do you mind that? If your computer,
it uses a one way cryptographic
Hash function, right?
And so it uses sh a to 56 which is
beautiful because the hash function is
something that is one way,
meaning that it's trivial for
you to calculate the output,
but it's extremely difficult for you to
actually reverse engineer this, right?
And find the input from the outlet,
which means I basically,
you need to brute force this function.
So in more technical terms specifically
where you're trying to do is you have a
nonce and arbitrary increment number
that you basically have to run this
function through this hash function,
right?
So you're trying to find a output that
starts with a leading number of Zeros.
And so the more zeroes that they,
this algorithm tells you that you need,
the harder the problem is exponentially,
right?
And so what it can do is it can adjust
to the difficulty of how many people were
mining bitcoin at any given time.
So say at the very beginning,
it was just a Toshi, right?
The Guy who made the coin,
he's minding his laptop and he can
do maybe one hash per seconds, right?
Of this algorithm, right? He
can calculate one Sha function.
So he's going through this whole thing.
So let's say he can do
60 hashes per minute,
and that's 600 hashes
per every 10 minutes.
So what would the bitcoin algorithm do?
It would say on average,
you're going to find the
solution to this problem.
Every one out of 600 of the tops,
right?
It's going to make it as difficult as
one off 600 temps. So on the average,
he'll find that every 10 minutes.
But now let's say ps two computers,
there's someone else starts
mining bitcoin. What happens?
Well now let's say they can both
mind that one has per second.
So now they're doing 1200
hashes per every 10 minutes.
So on theory you should see that they
would be finding a bit coin every five
minutes, right? But what the bitcoin
algorithm can do is every 2016 blocks,
it readjusted difficulty.
So it's like, all right,
how fast are we finding these bitcoins?
Let's actually change this algorithm
such that now on average you find a bit
coin every 1200 ashes as opposed
to 600 and so forth, right?
And so this is extremely important because
it actually means that not only is it
a future proof against many
people starting to mine bitcoin,
but it's also future proof
against technology that
makes it much easier to mine
bitcoin. So at the very beginning we
were using CPU is to mine bitcoin.
That was not that efficient,
right?
Then we move to gps because that can
paralyze the process much better.
And that was a lot faster.
But now we've actually progressed beyond
that to application specific integrated
circuits [inaudible] that can mind bitcoin
because that is better than anything
else because that's their
sole purpose in life, right?
Is to solve this Saj two 56 hash function.
And if this was gold,
right, we would be finding
bitcoins like every second. Right.
As opposed to every time,
minutes, but it's not gold.
And so it has adjusted perfectly
to the difficulty over time.
And difficulty is like this absurd number
now. It's like, exactly. Yeah. But um,
yeah. So let's, let's talk about some
other, but both at, so basically let's,
if we were to compare the
coin and gold together,
then this is the easiest way for me at
least to see what the value proposition
of bitcoin is.
So in one sense we have this currency
that has value because it's decentralized
to gold is decentralized and trustless.
Right? You don't have to trust that.
And part of the end, it's inherently
scarce. That's what gives it value.
Because people trust. If I hold gold,
no one's going to inflate this thing.
It's always going to retain value because
other people are gonna Trust at the
same scarce. Bitcoin on the other
hand has all those same benefits,
but ours even more predictable,
right? It's also decentralized.
No one controls it,
right?
No Central Bank can be like,
I'm going to print more bitcoins
because it's only by the code.
And the code is actually very strongly,
uh,
secured by this whole hashing algorithm,
right?
All these miners are mining bitcoin.
Um,
basically you would need at least 51%
of all the mining power in the world in
order to actually attack
bitcoin and change it. And then,
so there's some technicality there,
but I'm actually, I can get inside.
So the technicality is very specifically,
bitcoin holds the longest
chain to be the valid chain.
And so whoever has the most hashing
power is more likely to find blocks then
someone who has lost hashing power,
right?
So if you have 60% of the hashing power,
you're going to find blocks roughly
twice as fast as someone who has 30% of
hashing power at least
until the difficulty just
right. And so in that case,
if someone has 60% of the
hashing power, they could, um,
basically control the chain and
they can decide which blocks, uh,
include which transactions and so forth,
right?
So that's why if you have
over 51% of the mind power,
that's when it becomes directly possible.
It's a control bitcoin. But again,
because everyone's rationally
self interested and trying
to get as much money as
possible, there are a
lot of miners, right?
And they're all basically fully
decentralized across the world.
So it's very difficult for any one person
to get 51% of the power once bitcoin
gets so large. And so,
again, bitcoin's very secure,
very trust worthy because you don't
have to trust the central party.
There's no central point of
failure and it's inherently scarce,
but not only is inherently scarce,
it's also inherently scarce
and very predictable fashion.
So those are the benefits on top of gold.
But the other very important benefit,
the one that Sitoshi really wants to
drill down in is that is an easily
transactable currency. So you can go
around and like a pound of gold, right?
And like shave off.
Like it was small amounts to like pay
for coffee every day or like you know,
your bus ticket and all that. People would
be like, what can I use this for? Right.
And you really can't use gold that well.
In fact, it can only be used in person,
right? You can't send it to someone in
China easily. You can't mail them goal.
There's something about you could,
but it'd be terrible.
But a big point on the other
hand is extremely trivial.
Really easily transactable to
anyone in the world because it is,
this is something that people say is
like a downside. A bitcoin, right?
They don't understand that. Like
they're like, it's intangible, right?
Like at least with gold, I can hold it
in my hand, right? Or paper, you know,
like I can use this toilet paper
or kindling if I need it to. Right.
There's like some tangible value to it.
Bitcoin is this complete
intangible concept.
Actually that's a strength of Bitcoin,
right?
Because what it means is
that it's extremely easy to
transact in bitcoin across
any border,
right?
There's nothing but information
that constitutes the value
of bitcoin. Therefore,
you can transfer it extremely well.
And so by its native state,
it was designed such that,
you know,
is as easy to send a transaction
for a cup of coffee, $3 right?
Anywhere in the world locally or to
someone in China or to someone in the
Philippines, right? You can buy a car,
have it just as easily and justice
cheaply as you could buy a cup of coffee.
So such very powerful. And then, um, yeah,
and then so let's talk
about some hesitations that
people have and skepticisms
that people have about bitcoin. And so the
one, the first one that they say, right,
is that, you know, there's
no intrinsic value, right?
There's nothing here that I
can hold in my hands, right?
And so the counterpoints of that is,
this is a point made by a sapiens actually
really well where money ultimately is
just a denigration of the amount of trust
that people hold in that form of money.
So what I mean by that is actually if you
look at gold, right? You can say, sure,
gold has value because it can be
used as jewelry or it can be used for
industrial purposes, right? We put it
in our laptops and things like that.
But actually if you calculate the value
of goal today and how much of it is used
for industry and jewelry,
it's about 12% of the value of gold
is actually what's used for industry.
The rest of it all, 88% of it comes
from thin air, basically. Right?
Like what accounts for that
rest of the value? Well,
that's actually just the trust that
people have in it as a currency,
as a commodity,
as opposed to the value of as a
jewelry or no industrial use case.
Same for money today, right. You
say this thing has a physical,
tangible like value, right? I
have a piece of paper in my hands,
but actually how much
does it actually cost?
What is the value of that piece of paper?
It's about 5 cents for the government
to make a dollar bill. So what,
where is that 95 cents a bike?
Uh, you know, value come from,
it actually just comes from
trust in the u s dollar, right?
And it comes from trust that this thing
has value. So ultimately in that sense,
bitcoin can be seen as almost the most
pure form of money because there's
nothing but trust, right?
And as abstract away,
the need to have any tangible component
and there's just this intangible
component of trust and that's
where it's value comes from.
The other big question then skepticism
that people have about the coin,
it's like what can you actually use it
for? Right? And so they're like, Yo,
it's used for drug money,
right?
It's like this illegal money
that people spend or you know,
it's really just black market
stuff right now, right?
Like no one's actually using it to
like pay their salaries in this stuff.
And one that's actually changing
very quickly. But two, this is a,
bitcoin is a nascent technology
that's just been formed, right?
And it's something,
this is a criticism that has been
lobbied time memorial to basically every
single new technology is top
end, right? So this is a,
this is one of the most
interesting articles though.
It was a famous article back in 1995
by one of the first pioneers of the air
that actually, and so he wrote this huge
thing on Newsweek. He's like, all right,
everyone's like super excited
about the unit today, right?
They think it's going to be like this
magical thing that's going to change
everything about what we do.
Right?
And like this is just all bullcrap
because like they talk about things like
we're going to have libraries online,
we're going to have like town meetings,
we're going to have commerce
and businesses going to
somehow shift from offices
and malls, right. To
like the Internet. Right?
And like we're going to have things
that like make government more like a
democratic, like no. And then he's like,
this is just all totally false, right?
Like no CD ROM or online databases can
like replace Your newspaper, right?
Nothing like this is ever going to
happen to all that and fight they ass.
These are totally right.
He was absolutely correct back in 1995
none of these things were remotely
possible,
right?
There's all these like visions like
these far fetched plans that people had,
but none that were possible then. But
all of these things have come true today,
right?
And so that's where it's interesting in
that like people who are focused on what
bitcoin is today, I believe are taking it
from the wrong timescale, right? In fact,
even if you were to take bitcoin and just
compare it today versus other forms of
money, it's done incredibly well because
what gold has a 5,000 year headstart,
u s dollars have a 300 year head start.
If you were to compare them on the same
timescale, actually bitcoin, this one,
the best performing currencies
and nine years, right?
It's gone from basically nothing and value
to over $170 billion in value in just
nine years. And it out to constant as
a currency. The U s currency, right.
In nine years there was
actually hyper inflating,
it was basically going down to zero at
the same time that bitcoin has retained
its value in skyrocketed and
same thing of gold, right?
Gold's value is about seven point $5
trillion for the total sum of all the gold
that's ever been mined in the world.
Bitcoin 170,
that's about one 40th the size of the
whole market value of gold and something
like one,
2,500
of the time. Right? Like took to
get to that value. So that's uh,
that's the other point though is
interesting. So just really quickly, um,
and this beer wanting to diamond a little
bit into some of the technical pieces
because I think one thing
that's been engineers,
like why is it this has been done
in the past. There have been,
there have been currencies and other
things. Why haven't they worked? Um,
I think one thing that's
really interesting is thinking
about actually what are
the technological innovations within
bitcoin that has made this possible.
Ben Thompson,
some of these,
but one key problem that often comes
about is like there's the double spending
problem. How do you ensure that, you know,
money isn't sent to
two different accounts.
How do you ensure like authenticity of
transactions and all these things and
part of this kind of just comes down,
it's a very simple like cryptography,
breakthroughs in cryptography in the way
that was manifest from the bitcoin was
really, really profound. And it's a
specifically, right for those of you guys,
how many of you guys actually own a big,
like own some amount of cryptocurrency
or bitcoin? Just put quick show of hands.
Alright, awesome. One of the things,
one of the most profound things for me,
it was like, you know,
the first purchase of,
of cryptocurrency and one of
course it's under an exchange,
but then recognizing for example,
public private key pair is like
what does that actually mean? Um,
and I actually show of hands how
many people, how many people know,
like your private key is, or a public
key is within the context. Yeah.
A lot of you guys. Yeah, it's huge. Super,
super important. Um, decide, you know,
this basically a way for
people to communicate and,
and ensure the signature and the person
that is sending some message right is
actually factually correct transactions.
Another really interesting idea,
and this guy's actually goes
into the Eto blockchain, um,
in basically this idea that transactions
kind of point to the next transaction
to the blockchain.
You basically have a linked list of
different transactions that are coming in,
right? That are overall being
mined as Ben said. Right?
And then added basically to a note,
right?
Like basically the mining
is calculating this cash id.
You as a person send a transaction
that goes into a memory pool.
All these transactions
are put into a block.
That block is now appended to the node.
That node is then broadcasted rate the
is and broadcast broadcasters to the rest
of the network.
So this,
in terms of some profound
realizations here,
like bitcoin has this college,
like ultimately what are you trusting?
What are you putting your faith in?
It is that you have basically
this global ledger, right,
of everything that is happening and
complete transparency to how the system
works. You're not looking at a bank and
wondering how it's printing new money,
how everything is happening.
It's a completely clear and transparent
system enough that people can believe
and trust that the system works.
Right. That's so far, yes,
there are these clear technicalities
and points of vulnerability,
but that a lot of that, right, we, in
terms of how we're moving forward, right,
with skill,
um,
to fact that you need to take 51% of
all the mining half hour to be able to
actually conflict an attack. Like of
course there are all these problems,
but at the same time there's an
enormous amount of technical, um,
stepping that has been going forward
that has actually pushed a lot of
blockchain and a lot of bitcoin right
now and will continue to in the future.
So this also, now I'm brings
us to questions cause I know
we covered a lot about bitcoin and money
and a lot of these pieces and we just
want to take a really quick pulse to see
how people are feeling. Yeah. Question.
Oh, sorry. Yeah, we'll, yeah, we'll repeat
the question every time. And it said, oh,
great, awesome. Yeah. Question.
The valuable relative to the intrinsic
value of Bitcoin in particular goal was
for investment or it
for investment purposes.
The demand for billing for industrial
purposes is very less, right?
So if the price of gold
course started dropping,
the usage of gold skyrocket.
Absolutely. Yup. They did
that 12% of industrial use because it's
elastic means that it's going to act as
a dampener on the other 80%
of the speculative value. Yep.
Yes. John, just to quickly clarify, it
was, that was, that was a long one. Okay,
so just real quick rephrasing the
question. Ben Talks about gold,
12% being right, it's kind of industrial
purpose serves as a dampening effect.
How does that factor in like absolutely.
Great question.
We're talking about the elasticity of
gold. Exactly. Yeah, so that's beautiful.
And again,
anything that you guys saw that I said
that you guys have skepticism about,
that's where we want to
talk with right now. Right?
Because that's a Penn south
question because what that
means is that's basically
the transactional base for gold,
right?
It means that even if we wiped out
all of the value of currency, uh,
that gold has is a commodity or a currency
or like spectrum of value or anything
like that. There would be some use case
as industry. And you're right, right?
Like that mountain would go
up as the price of gold fell.
So it would provide a base value, right?
Well actually that base values, I'm just,
the thing that you were the abstract away
from like the rest of that currency's
value.
So what I mean by that is like let's say
what is that wants to see proof point.
So [inaudible] Gold's industrial value
is $1 trillion or something like that.
Right now I'm like f f everything else
was removed from no one trusted as a
currency.
It was only used for those industrial
purposes and that would be basically the
entirety of that economy,
right? There's like no. So
supply and demand is going to dictate the,
as the value drops,
you're going to have more industrial
uses. Absolutely. But there's a,
there's a cap on the market
cap of all that gold.
It's how much people are
willing to pay for it.
And so that would be at some point,
right there will be certainly lower
than seven point 5 trillion today.
So like for example,
I'm saying like how much does everyone
in the industry willing to pay for those
industrial use case of gold?
You're absolutely right,
but they were consumed all
the gold available, right?
They would certainly
consume all the supply,
but they wouldn't actually pay seven
point $5 trillion for it. Right.
They would pay some fraction of
that price. Does that make sense?
Like you're saying it's elastic,
right?
So they'll pay maybe half
the price of gold today,
they'll consume twice as much
gold, right? At half the price.
Is that what you mean by the
loss of sea? Correct. Yup.
Basically my is that even if everyone
today decided that, you know, oh,
I don't want to store my goal.
Absolutely.
It's not going to lose 80% of its value.
It's going to lose. Yup. Exactly. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. So to be specific, right?
It's like if the price goes down,
they're being consumed more gold, but
they're going to be paying less for it,
right? So that the market
cap is still dropping, right?
So because like if you're consuming
twice as much gold at half the price,
then you're still actually contributing
to the same market cap, right?
So that's basically what I'm saying is
that like, yeah, you're absolutely right.
It wouldn't drop all the way,
but that actually probably would
be somewhere in between. You know,
what they're paying for goal today
and we're gold as day, right?
So as certainly what drop,
but then again,
what we're focused on is
that difference in that, um,
the difference between all the money that,
um,
industry would pay for gold and
we're gold's prices today, right?
And so that's basically,
there is certainly some
difference there, but even so,
right? Like you could actually make
that same argument from Bitcoin, right?
There are actually transactional use cases
for Bitcoin, for example, you can say,
um, there is western
union, right? It basically,
eclipse is western union and
all of those payment purposes.
So Western Union is about the $10
billion currency a company today, right?
There's about $10 billion of value and
money transaction between people in the
states and like people in
the Philippines and so forth,
right in bitcoin actually has that same
kind of industrial use case, right?
And there are a lot of other use cases
that are coming out over time. So yeah,
um, basically the, there
is certainly value there.
What we're trying to segment the way is
that there are many different ways to
value what bitcoin is worth.
Gold is only one of those value cases.
And specifically when I talk about gold,
again,
there was just about the difference
in that industrial value abstracting
Galloway and then the remainder of
the value over time. And so, um,
you're right that there are like other
things that contribute to the price of
gold or a big one. And in fact, um,
this goes into something that we're
going to talk about later is a,
there are a lot of applications I can
build on top of bitcoin that contribute to
value beyond that just being
currency, right? But being a currency.
And the value that people hold it as a
currency is just one facet of all the
different reasons that bitcoin
will not value. So that's, yeah,
that's a good point.
We'll take,
we'll take questions just in the interest
of time. We have till 1:00 PM. So we'll,
we'll,
we'll now just batch all,
all the questions till the
end so we can cover it.
Some of the rest of this
stuff. Well, let's see.
Maybe we don't wonder if be
that great. It's 1240. Yeah.
Awesome. Cool, cool. Oh Wow.
That's fast
test.
Uh, so, uh, thanks. I think, um,
your explanation of why a bitcoin is
superior to US dollars or a gold was
fantastic.
The one like a question I have is
about kind of the volatility of like,
um,
so like if a,
a bank run or something like that can
really affect the value of US dollar.
It seems like there's a lot of events
that could also similarly affect the value
of a bitcoin, like a different governments
making regulations about it, et Cetera.
And just like looking at the price of
Bitcoin, it's always fluctuating wildly.
So how can it be a,
how can it be used as a useful form
of currency with that being the case?
That's a perfect question.
So there are a lot of things
there that you're talking about.
So one is like a yeah, f like a currency
is a measure of it's trust, right?
Then there are certainly things I can
demean that trust over time or damage that
trust. And you're exactly right. Like
say the u s is like, wait a minute,
why do we want people to use bitcoin
over the U s dollar? Let's ban bitcoin.
And they actually can write,
there's central points of
vulnerability they could ban exchanges.
So the question again is, um, what happens
with the volatility of Bitcoin, right?
It's like, um, how,
how can you have a currency that people
trust that people want to use as a
global digital daily currency?
F They can't believe that's gonna
hold its value while, right?
Because it keeps going up or it
keeps going down and so forth.
And so there are two,
two ways to answer that question.
One actually you can see the volatility
is something that has been decreasing
dramatically over time. So right now we
see swings maybe at most about 20%. Right?
But that, that is massive compared to
like most currencies. But actually over,
it's like at the very beginning,
right?
You could see bitcoin dropped
from like $30 down to $2. Right?
Or like a dollar down to like two sons.
And so actually right now the volatility
that we see in system is far less than
it was before.
And this will only continue to decrease
over time as it gains more adoption.
Right? It's just a function
of like a small cap versus
a large cap. And so that's,
that's one part of it.
The other part of it though is a,
is a really good question that like,
um, a lot of people do say even,
so even if you have a currency that,
um,
is just appreciating or like a, the
volatility isn't going down. Um,
a deflationary currency over time is
like a, a bit of a problem as well,
that people are encouraged to keep
their money as supposed to spend it.
And there's some questions there,
but then price stability and of
itself is a valuable thing, right?
Like you can't say one that cup of
coffee is one bitcoin today because in 10
years is going to be like $17,000 and
you're like, wow, that sucks. Right? Um,
but what is interesting
is that are actually some
solutions around this, right?
So how the US government does it is they
have central bank and the central bank
makes sure that the money always
in plates at like two or 3% a year,
no matter what happens to the economy,
right?
And they can do this through two things.
They can inflate the money supply when
there's more demand for it, right?
So when more people have trust in the
US dollar, they just print more money.
They print like a billion new dollars
and they can actually capture that money
themselves,
right?
That's real money that the Princeton
about dilutes hunger with loss, right?
So that puts the money, the value of
the US dollar down. And in the reverse,
what they can do is they can actually
issue bonds rates to constrict the money
supply. So when people lose trust in
the US dollar is starting to lose money.
What they do is they
issue bonds at a yield.
And what that does is it reduces the
amount of money and the system thereby
driving up the price of each us dollar.
And actually you can do
this in the world today too.
So there's an extremely interesting
currency that's coming out.
It's called base coin and they do exactly
that's there an algorithmic central
bank. So what that means is they
basically buy their algorithm,
not through a normal central bank
that's controlled by like five people.
They are able to say f
the money supply grows,
you're able to print more money to
dilute the my supplies such as the prices
have remained stable.
And in the case that the money supply,
people are losing faith in this thing
and they're selling their base coin,
they can actually issue bonds the
redeemed in chronological order with
increasing yields such that you know,
f you at any point believe that base coin
will remain that's retained its value
and like go back to the
$1, you know, stable value,
then you would be extremely rationally
motivated that's buy these bonds because
you'll get free yield on it,
right when the price goes back,
when the trust is remain a retained
again in the future you'll just get about
10% more bass coins or something
like that. So that's actually,
it's very important to find a
system that has priced stability,
but at the same time you want to capture
the value from the growth of that
currency over time.
Right?
So these are like two different
things that we're trying to do and the
government does this by just saying,
don't worry about it.
We'll take all the money and you guys
don't have to worry about this value.
That's appreciated, right?
We'll just capture ourselves.
But ideally you would like to
capture value yourself, right?
Like you want your bitcoins to go from
$5 today to $17,000 right in the future,
but you also want to be able to
price things in this currency. Well,
how do you solve that one said, well,
you can have a system where you can say,
for example,
this is,
this cup of coffee is three bitcoins and
three bitcoins are always a dollar and
in five years instead you still have,
uh,
all the value that came from the
growth of that currency. Instead,
what you have now is it's still three
bitcoins is still worth $3, right?
Each bitcoin still worth a
dollar each in five years inside.
Now you just have 17,000 bitcoins that
are all worth a dollar each, right?
So that's an interesting system where
you can have price stability but also
still capture value from the growth of
the currency over time. So Yup. Yup.
And so forth.
So yeah.
So now basically when we'll jump into
is some of the most promising future
applications of bitcoin and
blockchain technology to,
so what we've seen in the past.
Yes. These really exciting. Yeah.
And I know we're running short on time,
so really quickly just for theory
and also gets into into some really,
really interesting pieces. Turing
complete language, amazing in that,
that actually for those of you
guys that know what I mean,
like a theory of high,
they EVM,
we're just trading Turing complete
allows the creation of basically, right.
Anything that you could
potentially coat up, right?
Like in any sort of language you can
actually translate into a Theorem,
which is one of the
coolest things from my end.
Viping cause now you can actually have
complex interactions that middleman right
in market makers are 10 tend to perform
right now actually be able to be
codafide into smart contracts.
Right.
And then actually be implemented on the
network with some financial base, um,
at the back of it.
So I think we'll just,
we'll skip through this
because I knew we were running.
So I'll give a quick example of like the,
the future potential of what smart
contracts can do. So for example,
basically what bitcoin has done this,
it's disintermediate this middleman,
the government,
right?
The government was what you needed to
trust before as a third party that could
control and create your money.
And you gave them trust because they're
trustworthy and they're the only person
who can be trustworthy.
But now in fact, you,
anyone can create their own currency
and people can trust it because you know
that like it will be to by this
code, right? That's exciting.
But actually what's more exciting is that
you can actually do this with any kind
of industry, right? So you can do the same
thing. For example, if the legal system,
so a smart contract is just a piece
of code that dictates what happens.
But like on top of it, you know,
there's some currency aspect.
So let's take an example.
Say you want to make a bet
with some random person that
Donald Trump will remain
present, not the end of 2018 right?
And so today, if you were to say,
let's do this a hundred dollars bet,
right?
And if you did it with
complete random stranger,
you wouldn't because you'd have to trust
that they would like honor this, right?
And so in today's world,
right,
let's say even if you have
a written contract with this
random person and you're
like,
all right,
we'll pay each other a hundred dollars
based on who wins this fat, right?
I think that Donald Trump will be
president. You think that they won't.
And then at the end of that time say, I'm
right, right? And that person's like, oh,
nevermind. I don't want pay
you. Well, what's your recourse?
You'd have to go through the legal system,
right?
And like the cost and the time of
going through the legal system,
which is this extremely inefficient kind
of middleman that arbitrates all these
discussions today is something that
would almost certainly be more than like
this a hundred dollar battery.
So it would never be worthwhile
for you to go through our system,
therefore you will never be able
to make a bet like this, right?
So there's huge inefficiency that reduces
the ability for us to have all these
economic transactions, right?
In fact, with a smart contract,
we can completely obviate that system,
right?
We can abstract the way the need to
trust this third party to make a bet like
this. In fact, we don't have to
trust the other part of the law.
We don't have to know them.
They could be some random person on the
internet and we would say, all right,
Alison, bomb. They want to make this bet.
So both of them agreed
to the smart contract,
they put their money into the smart
contract, it goes into escrow, right?
So now the smart contract holds $200
and then at the end of 2018 the smart
contract can ping an
oracle or source of truth,
or there's a game directly secure way
for you to actually have an economic like
incentive for people to tell you the
truth. And then at the end of that time,
it just says, all right, Alice won the
bet. We send all $200 to Alice, right?
So now you can see that you can actually
have really interesting things where
you reduce a lot of inefficiency and you
reduce the need for a middleman to make
all these kinds of applications
possible. Yup. Yeah, exactly. Well said.
Sarah.
Fundamental value proposition
is abstracting the need
like to trust and depend
on any given middleman.
And that's like, you know,
a lot of the core value proposition.
For example,
if I'm in a lot of the d applications,
so d apps that are being developed
on top of the Theorem is that you now
basically have this currency right
in which, right? For example,
the code and ether specifically as a
currency is being used to actually run the
logic within the code,
right? They were just like,
one of the coolest like paradigms is
this idea of a world computer, right?
That is now decentralized, transparent
in terms of how it functions, um,
and allowing people to write
these functionalities functions,
these applications in the same way.
For example,
on top of the Internet there are
websites and other things created.
So this flow information and
this flow of logic in particular,
this is actually my first foray into
cryptocurrency was a theory because it was
so exciting from a technical perspective.
Um,
and see if we actually think about
this in down the line, right?
We have blockchain, we are actually in
code complex pieces of logic, right?
In some sort of right way through
solidity and through smart contracts.
I'm actually able to exit a lot of this
stuff. What can we do with that, you know,
as a result.
Right?
And I think for those of you have been
following with the ICO space and a lot of
crypto projects, um, this
actually opens up some really,
really interesting doors in terms of what
people can do on top of something like
a ethereum during Erc
20 token rate,
which is like kind of the standard in
terms of tokens that are built on top of
the ethereum chain. So using the theory
on blockchain to, to exit specific things,
um, as well as like, you
know, other doctrines that
have come. So in particular,
what we're going to do is actually take
stream what we're working on, um, as a,
as a somewhat of a case studies terms,
thinking about actual value accrued
in a lot of these crypto parties.
So we were going to get
to their questions too.
So I'm going to actually just do a very
quick explanation of all the things that
are relevant in like what
is an exciting use of, uh,
watching technology that
we see. And then, you know,
if you guys want to learn
more about anything, just
less less, no one questions,
you guys have some very specifically,
what's the fascinating thing now is we
basically democratize the creation of
money, right? There's no
longer a domain of a monopoly.
So specifically the monopolies I could
before create money or governments, right?
They're the only ones who had the trust
that people would place to be able to
create money. Now anyone can do it.
So what can you do with that? Well,
you can actually do things, for example,
like make sector specific currencies.
What's extremely interesting about that.
And what I mean by that is a currency
that specifically just tracks one industry
or one sector or one economy.
For example, in our case,
we're tracking video streaming
or content distribution. Well,
what can you do in that case, what you
can do to extremely interesting things.
One, you can shield that currency
from global volatility. So right now,
for example,
there are many different factors that
impact the price of a US dollar, right?
Maybe oil prices fall somewhere in the
world, or like they rise or something.
And like that impacts you even if you
have nothing to do with oil, right?
Even if you have nothing to do with the
economic policy of the government and so
forth, right? You're in like, you're just
like a video maker, right? They're like,
why am I being impacted by this? We'll
actually, no, you don't have to be, right?
You can have a currency that specifically
is valued based on that's use case in
a specific industry such that the other
fascinating thing that happens here is
you have incentive alignment within
this industry where we can create strong
motivations to, uh, create a virtuous
cycle of increasing network effects.
And so what I mean by that is no,
you can create the currency that people
all directly benefit from when they
gross such that you're highly
motivated to make this industry go.
So let's take a very simple example.
So we have say a stream token, right?
So let's say we created this currency.
We have 100,000 streams tokens,
it's a completely finite number, right?
And let's say for example, in our case,
right? The use cases are
like live streaming tips.
It's a $5 billion industry right now, or
Patriot loss models and so forth, right?
People sending money from
users to concentrators. So
say people convert there,
other currencies into this currency,
you use it for those cases.
Now people have come here with
$100,000 of that, those currencies.
So now we have 100,000 streams,
logins, $100,000 as a market cap.
So you are the expect each stream token
has about a dollar value, but oh yeah,
perfect. And now let's say
this grows over time, right?
There's more people want to use this
currency for the goods and services I can
provide. We now have saved. The
thing grows too. In my example,
I'll just say $500,000 right?
So now we have 100,000 stream tokens,
a market cap of $500,000
that's about $5 per token.
And this is the naive model
that's a bitcoin takes, right?
It's just that you capture the value
from the growth for the US economy by
basically having each unit of
value be worth more over time.
That's actually not the most
interesting thing that you can do.
What you can do in this case is actually
similar to what central bank can do.
You can emit more tokens. So let's say
we actually met 400,000 new tokens.
So now we have $500,000 in this economy.
We have five and 2000 tokens.
So we don't change the size of the
economy by printing more tokens.
But over time,
discounting velocity of money,
you are the imagined that it would revert
to this fundamental mean where we have
a dollar per token stove,
right? You have 500,000 tokens,
$500,000 but we have literally
created $400,000 of real new money,
right? So what can we do with
that? Well, interestingly enough,
we can distribute that back to everyone
who has contributed to the growth in
this economy over time to
incentivize them to grow the economy.
So let's say we split this in the most
simple way. We could split 50 50 right?
We take 200,000 of these new tokens that
we made with $200,000 of real value.
We give it to everyone
who held tokens today.
So if you had one stream token for dollar,
now you have three stream tokens worth
a dollar each, but three times as much.
But we also have $200,000 of new money
that we created, and now that money,
we can actually distribute back
to say constant creators, right?
The people who have made
these videos such a,
now they have a revenue stream
without any direct costs to users that
incentivizes them strongly such that
if you have say a million views,
you would just possibly,
if you have like 50% of the views of
everyone on the spot, what to say, right?
You have $100,000 that we give you
in stream tokens for free, right?
For having contributed
to that network effect.
So you can strongly in gender or someone
wanting to contribute to that network.
In fact,
over time,
and so now we've created a new revenue
stream that basically was once the domain
of just governments,
right?
It's a silent tax and everyone
who holds US dollars day is a,
if you take the u s dollar,
you would see that the US economy
does keep growing over time, right?
So as the u s economy
kept growing over time,
if you have a finite supply of US dollars,
you are the imagine that
each year scholars should
have more buying power over
time, but doesn't, right? It actually
depreciates by about 2% or 3% every year.
And the reason for that is because while
that value has to be going somewhere,
right, someone must be capturing that
value and it's the government, right?
When they print more money,
they captured themselves.
And for the first time
we have an opportunity to
actually distribute that back
to the people who are actually responsible
for the growth for that economy over
time. It's not just one real quick thing.
There's a lot more to it, but yeah,
while open up for questions,
you guys have anything you want
to dive in more detail? Yeah.
So what are the biggest risks
for cryptocurrencies? Yeah,
that's a great question.
So personally my philosophy is
this, right? I see that. Um, oh,
that's a great question.
Yeah.
What are the biggest risks
for cryptocurrencies today?
So there are a lot of things that can
happen and it is, um, a lot of them,
I would consider it to be black swan
events that are almost inevitable in the
short term, but in the long
term. So what we can see is, um,
I actually considered cryptocurrency to
be, um, this concept of expected value,
right? Like plus or minus expected value.
It's a term that's often used in poker,
right? So in poker it's basically a
dilatation of probability. It's like no.
I would say maybe even if bitcoin
has a 90% chance of failure,
it can be a good bet for you to put some
of your money into f in that 10% that
succeeds, you expect to
succeed more than 10 x, right?
Then that's a positive expected value.
But so let's see,
what are those things that
could cause it the hub? No,
I actually do believe that's still,
it's an extremely high risk speculative
investment. Right? And so that's sort of,
again,
it may be worth your money played being
pulled into this thing if you believe
that the expected value is over that.
So in the short term,
this is why I don't day trade,
right?
I think it's actually easier to see and
predict what possibilities they coin may
have in the for the long
term than the short term.
What this world of the media things
that can happen. For example,
what are the things that actually caused
the price of bitcoin and ethereum and
all these things to drop the most?
There are black swan events that happened
that you fundamentally can't predict.
You can have pretty good assurance
over time that they will happen,
but you don't know when they'll happen.
So for example,
in 2013 the price of bitcoin went all
the way up to 20 a $1,200 and then the
creative immediately because
Mt Gox was hacked, right? Mt.
Gox lost hundreds of millions of dollars
that immediately made the price fall
and become stagnant for the
next three years, right?
They went all the way down to less
than $200. So over 80% or 85% fell.
And for example, another thing happened
with the Dow. So ethereum again,
has all these enormous potential,
uh,
applications and that you can create
smart contracts, smart contracts. Again,
those Turing complete code, that code can
basically do anything. So for example,
they have this concept of these
centralized autonomous organizations.
So Take Uber, for example, right?
Uber is a company that
technically it's a company today,
but it's really just code, right?
There's no reason you can adjust,
have this code via Turing complete thing
that you put into the blockchain and
they would just run by itself and you
wouldn't even need a company to run it,
right? They would just be decentralized
and autonomous who'd run by itself.
And so the first concept was this thing
that they created that was called the
Dow,
right?
There was like self names and there
was an investment funds and they said
everyone put your money into the dao
and we're going to have you all vote on
where you want this money to be invested.
And they thought this was a good idea.
I'm a little skeptical but you know they
put $150 million into this thing and
people were super excited but it didn't
even cross because like they made bad
investments. It failed because
someone found that code is law,
right? But curve is fallible. Curve is
written by humans that can make mistakes.
And so the code had an exploit where
someone could actually siphon the funds
directly into child doubt, right? And
like basically control of themselves.
And so they were like, holy
crap, this is terrible.
Atherium was rising all the
way up to $22 at that point.
And then the Dow had this hack,
right?
Someone stole $50 million and
it actually has a hard fork.
All the doubts and re uh,
Re uh, retrieved the funds.
But in that time etherium fell down
to $7. Right? So in the short term,
those are the existential risks I see.
Right? Regulation can happen, right?
China's size, we banned all ics that
creatives market, the u s is like, Yo,
we're going to ban exchanges,
right? That craters market.
Those are all the short term
existential risks that we see.
Maybe some of those are long,
large enough that they, you know,
so far damaged the trust in bitcoin.
That doesn't get to long term.
But actually I think these are all
things that like you can't predict window
happened or how though happens
or any of those things.
They're just like a inextricably tied to,
you know,
just like uncertainty and
the sorts, everybody in the
long term actually I think,
um,
there are the only,
like the big risks is that some like
the governments or something, right?
Like trying to tackle this thing
and talk it so far that like, um,
it doesn't get off the ground or they
replace it or say quantum computing for
example,
like technically the house function
that protects bitcoin is something that
isn't computationally
impossible to reverse engineer.
It just computationally hard.
There's no technical technology
today that can say like,
we can reverse engineer a cryptographic
one way hash function easily,
but in the future, maybe with constant
Peter's, it'd be really trivial for us to,
you know, brute force, that solution.
So those are things that can happen,
but also at the same time, um, the code
itself can be modified over time. Right.
So I'm can fork it and just
have a system that's resistant.
Yeah.
It seems pretty hard to make
kind of obvious decisions. Yup.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
That's a great question. Thanks. Yeah.
So basically it seems like it's pretty
hard to come to consensus in the bitcoin
community, right? So how are decisions
made? And that's a great question.
And actually this is a difference
between the lot of different systems or a
bitcoin itself specifically has a hard
time consuming coming to consensus
because there's no clear leader.
So this is the Toshi knock and Barlow
made the coin and then think just left,
right? Like at some point.
And he's like, all right,
like it seems like this thing's taken off.
I only have to be here anymore.
So he's no longer there.
So what happens now is that there are a
lot of ideological splits and camps that
now have influence over bitcoin.
And in fact,
so there are people who
have real influence.
And then there are people who are
like these, uh, like leaders, right?
Thought leaders in the case.
So for example, this is
what happened very recently.
Um,
a huge question was the scaling debate.
So bitcoin is now actually reasonably
expensive to use for small micro
transactions.
And the reason for that,
and it's because the blockchain
is actually an incredibly
inefficient system to,
uh,
convey information because it's something
that's replicated across every single
computer that is a full node,
right?
And so you want to keep this ideally
as small as possible. And so right now,
all blocks are limited to
being one megabyte in size.
And this is a huge problem in some some,
uh,
philosophies because it means that there
are only a tiny amount of transactions
that can be fit in each block
and they'd give him point.
And specifically miners are rationally
self interested in accepting transactions.
I paid them the most money. So with
every transaction you spend, you signed,
you can specify how much money you
want to go as a reward to minors.
And of course, if they can only
fit a finite number in here,
they're going to fit the ones I
paid them the most money, right?
So that means that now transactions,
if you want them to happen quickly,
they take a lot of money. It's
a lot of people were like, well,
this is a huge problem. While we saw
that with the most intuitive solution,
which has just increased the block size,
right?
So that's what happened with bitcoin cash.
There are a lot of these people who
are like, well, this is obvious.
Let's just make the block size larger,
right?
Let's go from one megabytes
to eight megabytes and
that's going to be sufficient
to solve this transactional problem.
But a lot of people also think that this
is a short term shortsighted solution,
right? Because it makes the
problem go away right now,
but it's not going to make the problem
go away forever because you know,
increasing the blockchain is something
that's going to be finite and as more
transactions happen, it's still
going to be a problem in the future.
So you're basically kicking the
bucket down the road at the same time.
It also makes the blockchain so large,
right?
It makes it eight times as large going
such that it will be much more difficult
for it to be decentralized for people to
be able to actually hold enough data to
make this possible.
And so what happened in this case as
it was extremely difficult to come to
consensus because there is no one clear
person who was a spiritual leader, right?
Take an example for ethereum
where when the Dow hack happens,
actually within a month they hard forks,
right?
And they actually made the new currency
that reverse that transaction because
there was clear, uh, leaders, right?
Like Vitalik was like, all right,
like I made this thing, right. I
think this is the right decision.
People followed him and believes
in very strongly with bitcoin.
There's Bitcoin core,
right?
There are these core developers that
like technically contribute to the code,
but they don't actually
have that much power, right?
Because they contribute to code.
But the people who have a lot
of power are miners, right?
Because they're the people who actually
provide the security behind the system.
And so those people are actually very
rationally interested in increasing the
block size change size.
Because the alternative solution that
people are proposing right now is the
lightening network. So the
lightening network, for example,
is an off chain second layer solution.
So what we mean by that
is transactions they take,
the philosophy of transactions on
the blockchain are always going to be
inherently limited in size,
right?
We can't possibly fit every
single transaction you ever
want on the blockchain.
So instead,
why don't we just take transactions off
the blockchain and the make extremely
cheap, extremely fast, uh, transactions
on the, off the blockchain possible.
And so what you do now is you opened
basically war called payment channels and
how you open the payment channel
to say Alison, Bob, right?
They want to send money back to
each other. So they have $100 each.
They do a multisignature transaction.
So they both agreed to basically, uh,
put one transaction on the
blockchain. So they put, um,
they both signed this reduction,
they put $100 in this thing,
they opened a payment channel,
and then in that payment channel,
what they can do is they can send money,
if only back and forth to each other in
the form of ics without closing this on
the blockchain itself without paying
any costs. So maybe they paid $3, right?
So let's make this first transaction that
goes on the blockchain and then in the
future, say Alice is like, Oh, I owe you
some dollars for like a Uber ride, right?
So she pays $7 to Bob and now their
balances updates such an Alice now has $93
in this Iou, right? And Bob has
$107, right? And they can sign,
say a thousand transactions back and
forth on this IOU thing before suddenly in
blockchain doesn't matter, right? Because
as long as they both have some none,
zero balance rate,
they can keep sending money back and
forth and then say a thousand transactions
live, they finally decide to close this
thing. They pay another like $3 right?
To actually finally settle.
It's like Allison's up with $50 in.
Bob Ends up with 150 they sell it on
the blockchain and now they've only paid
for two transactions on the blockchain.
Even if they sent a thousand transactions
back and forth to each other, right?
And this actually can scale because you
can have nodes that connect to other
nodes. Even if you don't have a direct
connection from the other party.
Say Bob is connected with Kathy,
right?
And like Alice now can send money to Kathy
through Bob even if they don't have a
direct connection.
So through hubs you can basically send
money to anyone through the system and
you really uh, solve kind of this a
problem with like on changers actions.
You just move most of
transactions off chain.
And so the problem is this is a solution
that makes a lot of sense to a lot of
the people because it is a like longterm
cited solution that will like obviate
the problem with like we always need to
keep increasing the block size but is
against the rational self interest
and minors. Right? Because my,
there is don't make any money when
you do off change his actions,
they only make money when you put
transactions on the blockchain, right?
And so of course they want all the
transactions to stay on the blockchain.
So that's why they were the advocate for
say an eight docs bunching size. Right?
And so because there are these like
mal lines, economic incentives,
it's really hard to come to consensus
even beyond the fact that there's no, uh,
economic leader.
So it is a problem.
Yeah.
I think I saw you as hers
a little bit.
Exactly.
Is it de facto? I mean, I, I find it,
that'd be, yeah. The other incentives,
like it doesn't have to be a government
want to
go.
Yeah. So that's a great question.
So basically you're right.
Like bitcoin itself is
inherently scarce in the sunset.
Like bitcoins will not increase the value,
but people can just make many
different other currencies.
So that was the question is like,
is it really scarce?
Are cryptocurrencies really scarce?
Because you can just have infinitely many
different cryptocurrencies and that's
actually correct. Right? Well, it's the
same reason that like, you know, um,
gold for example, no one
has to use gold, right?
There are many other elements that
we could use as a store of value,
but people don't use those.
Right?
So ultimately it comes down to what
trusts do people have in these other
currencies are created.
And the fact that bitcoin itself has
been forked thousands of times, right?
And like the vast majority of those forks
technically are indistinguishable from
bitcoin but have no value, right? Because
people have in place on the trust in it.
So the real question is,
will people actually wants a place trust
in something else that's not bitcoin
itself? And Yeah, you're absolutely right.
Maybe there are forced utility
use cases, like you say, right?
All these banks or consortium of like
retailers get together and they were like,
in order to use Amazon, you have to use
Amazon point or something like that,
right? And then that give us like some
force utility to people wanting to use US
system. And that's certainly
a possibility, right?
Certainly other cryptocurrencies
have value, right? Like right now,
bitcoin's worth under $70 billion. The
total market is like $300 billion, right?
So clearly people want to put faith in
other currencies about the same time,
right? It is scarce, right?
Bitcoin itself is scarce.
And as long as people
want to trust Bitcoin,
and there are a lot of the reasons
that you actually want to trust bitcoin
because one, like, sure, they have
the first mover advantage, right?
They already have a large body of trust,
but also something needs to be a lot
better than bitcoin to actually replace it
on like this a reason trust, right? Like
if someone made exactly the same bitcoin,
there's no reason for someone to want to
do that. Right? So then the question is,
is there anything that can be a lot
better than bitcoin? I think that is, um,
that's really up to birds debate
and I think there's a lot of, uh,
evidence for that not being the case.
It's, um, bitcoin, like people say,
for example,
ethereum is a really easy case of like,
of course people want to use the theory
because it's so much more useful, right?
Like you can program
anything you want on it.
It can be for almost any
of these applications.
You can make the Amazon coin on top of it,
right?
You can make an Erc 20 token
that lives on top of ethereum.
So why would someone want to use bitcoin?
Well,
actually there are a lot of trade
offs, right? With all of these things.
Bitcoin takes very few promises.
Bitcoin promises to be a
currency that works really well.
You theory and makes an enormous amount
promises and each of those promises is
something that can damage trust if
they don't fulfill that promise.
So specifically you can actually have
smart contracts as a second layer on top
of the coin itself.
So you can have a risk smart contract
that I'm works basically the same as like
Ethiopian smart contracts would,
but etherium has designed that to
be part of its base layer, right?
So the scripting language, free theory,
Ms Turing, complete audience base layer,
this is really bad for a lot reasons,
possibly because the scripting language
can be very poorly written. And uh,
it can be like very subject to more
exploits and vulnerabilities and bitcoin
itself would, right? Because bitcoin
is kept the tax space very small.
And so for example,
if we're hearing,
we've actually seen this happen a
lot of times, or there's a Perry,
the multisite hack that happened recently
where they lost like $150 million,
right? And that was because
the guy, this is lower,
the guy who made the
etherium yellow paper, right?
He basically created the
scripting language on ethereum
called solidity, right?
And he used to prepare the,
but the,
the scripting language like is not
that well written to be very secure,
such that like he introduced a very
simple bug basically where, uh,
he called you,
you wanna like initialize a library
function and like you want to save on gas
costs, you reuse the same
code over and over again.
So he initialized this library.
But in the library there's a function
that you could call that would basically,
uh, reinitialize a wallet and
assign a new owner to this wallet.
And so of course, this is a function that
you only want to be able to call once,
right?
To start this thing.
And then no other person should be able
to be able to call this function method.
But unfortunately what he did was he
wrote this code and he didn't realize that
he actually put an edge case in this
code where it said if you send money,
this is to create a multisig wallet.
So if you guys are familiar with multisig
wallet is a wallet where you can have
multiple owners such that you have three,
say three out of five people need to sign
a transaction before it actually goes
live. And so in this case, it's supposed
to be the most secure thing ever, right?
Because like you don't have
one central point of failure,
you have like five different points
of failure. So it's a lot more robust.
But in fact you could just circumvent
this whole system if you actually have to.
Code itself is vulnerable,
right?
And so that's what happened because he
had an exception handler where it was a
very friendly exception handler.
It said basically that f you tried to
call a function that wasn't defined in the
code for the multisig itself.
Don't worry about it.
We'll actually search our libraries and
see if the function is called there.
Right? And so, uh, if the
function is defined there,
then we'll just call it for you.
So then someone just like called these
like multisig wallets and like call the
function to reinitialize wall and sign
themselves as the owner and just went
through.
Right.
And so that's a problem with like maybe
having more functionality on top of like
bit coin itself.
Just as one example for why bitcoin
actually is like a very well done system
that may be hard for
something as supersede.
I actually don't. So I actually disagree
with Ben on some of this stuff. Um,
I think so from my perspective,
I think I, with the scarcity, um,
I mean I think that the engineering
problem, I think for example,
having a currency as a
store of value right there,
there is a lot in the same
way that gold is function,
there is a lot of value within that.
Um, I actually think like, man,
this is like giving the incentive
alignment. We have minors,
different different reasons for
different parts of Bitcoin to evolve. Um,
it's actually really interesting it also
thinking about presenting the proof of
work right now. Right now, what that's
led to is just giant mining farms,
for example,
in China and other places in which
there's been an enormous amount of
computational power spent generating
random numbers that has no real utility or
value. Right. In the same
way, like for example, if you
look at it [inaudible] case,
um,
the differences that you're actually
using computational power density run code
on the network. So I
think it's interesting, I,
I from my perspective is that I think
blocked like there is going to be a
solution,
whether it's Bitcoin,
inevitably I think it has the
clear first mover advantage,
but I think you know better,
for example,
proof of like better proof
of whatever it might be. Um,
systems might actually end up becoming
better then you might have you taken,
how does that evolve? Like I think
this is all up in the air, um,
in terms of what there's
so much innovation going to
happen and Bitcoin is just
one that we all know and we think,
um,
but whether it becomes a clear
winner in the long run, like, right.
I think there's,
there's a lot of debate clearly right
around a lot of this stuff that's
happening and what technologies can be
better. So this is something, but it's,
I think once that,
one takeaway is that they're like,
scarcity is important in terms of
people trusting within the currency,
but there are clearly problems with what
we have already and there's going to
clearly need to be innovative solutions
to scaling going forward. Um, yeah,
I grew up fat. Right.
It's not a binary system.
It's not like when
they're takes all right.
There's certainly room for many different
players and specifically because there
are tradeoffs with every system
that you would implement. Yeah.
There are two systems that may
work for different purposes, right?
Yup, Yup. Yeah. We can
do, if you think of all
the, Yup, Yup,
Yup,
Yup.
Totally getting the approvers of Bitcoin
or I can put it in cool switch that
holds a on the paper it or like try
to remember it in my head's like, Yup,
it's like die those goons, all
this, whatever. So absolutely,
absolutely perfect way to score
and I know exactly what you are.
That's great. Sure.
No one takes my backpack right there.
Well, anyway, yeah. So very
specifically to your, to your point,
that's a great question. So the
question again was, you know,
security seems like a trade
off with Bitcoin, right?
Because those fundamental value
proposition is you own your own money,
but with great power comes
great responsibility, right?
If you control your own money, then
it's hard to spend and if you spend it,
it can be compromised. Like all these
things, you can lose your own coins,
you can lose your private keys. So status
should you keep it on like an exchange,
right? Like which takes analog
of a bank, but then, you know,
the bank had just like lose its money
or like go out of business or get hacked
itself and all these things.
There are these fundamental trade off.
So that's a great question.
I would venture to say that that
actually is something that today is, um,
certainly in its nascent form,
right?
I really do say as like analogous
to the Internet in 1995, right?
There was like a clunky,
terrible thing that was extremely
difficult for most people lose, right?
Like any grandmother now can use Facebook
because you pressed some buttons,
right? And then works or Google
or youtube. But like back then,
and it's like you have to understand how
https works or TCP Ip and like a right
curve then like a terminal command line,
right?
And that's the same thing
with the system today, right?
Like you have to understand how the keep
your cryptographic private key secure,
right? How the sunlight's
and some random heck story.
Now just write what that even
means and all this stuff.
And so you're absolutely right.
It is a problem today and it's very scary.
But even today we can already see
good solutions coming out, right?
So there's this fundamental question
that you have with like, you know,
cold storage versus hots,
this hot storage, right?
So hot wallet is something that touches
the air and that you assume that
anything that communicates with the year
and that is fundamentally compromised
because Erin has a fundamentally
insecure layer, right?
So the most secure thing that people do
is you keep your money on something that
has never touched you in that, right?
So what you can do is, for example,
you have a laptop that you never
do anything with near enough for.
You just download the program on it and
like you generate your random, you know,
private key and public key pair,
and then you put your money in
there and then you never touch it.
So no one on the end that could
possibly steal this money.
But that's extremely arduous,
hard to like use.
And someone could like steal your laptop
or your laptop burns off burst and blue
like that, right? And it's gone.
And so the actually today we can
already see some alternatives.
So while I personally use, for
example, our hardware wallets,
so hall Grunewald solve this problem.
Well,
because it's basically an air gap system
that does allow you to use the money,
but also keep it secure
and away from the Internet.
So the two largest ones are Tresor and
ledger nano s and they take two different
purchase to it.
But let's talk about the treasure.
So trezor is beautiful because what it
does is it's basically a hardware, uh,
piece of thing that you actually hold
that actually stores your private keys on
it.
And then what it does is you connected
through like micro Usb to your computer.
But um,
the private keys,
we'll never be transmitted to
the actual internet or you know,
your computer or anything
like that because all you
actually have to do to send
the transaction these,
you have to sign a transaction
you wear for your private key.
You don't have to transmit
the private key yourself.
So what it does is it actually
signs the transaction.
So what you do is use software on your
computer and it's like, all right,
let's send $1,000 to some random address,
right? And then it's like, all right,
let's send this transaction
to your life or your treasure.
It sends it to treasure.
And then on the treasury side,
all has to do as a scientist transaction
on the treasury itself and then ascends
the signature to your computer, but never
send your private key, right? So again,
now you have a system where you have
to think that's aircraft that is, uh,
safe in of itself directly at least,
right?
But that you're able to use every day
for sending transactions. So that's,
you know, that's one example. Again,
multisignature [inaudible]
are another example, right?
It's something where you have control
of yourself over this thing and yet you
have like a multiple points of failure,
right?
It's not just like you lose your one
thing and you know, it's all gone, right?
You can do multiple things there. And
even so like, um, I think over time,
realistically if this becomes
adopted as a global curtsy,
we'll see even more security
measures in place. For example,
Coinbase has insurance on
all their hot wallets, right?
So actually I do keep some
of my coins on coin base.
My whole thesis is don't keep all
your eggs in one basket, right?
So I keep telling about my treasure.
I keep some of my ledger,
I keep some in Coinbase and all over
all of these places because coin base,
maybe they, they like this is their
job, right? To keep this money secure.
Chances are they're doing a much better
job of it then like I myself could like
replicate. And so for
example, what they do, right?
It's like they actually do Samir
[inaudible] secret sharing.
They split up all their private keys
into like multiple redundant parts and no
one employee or no one person has control
over each of these parts. But like, um,
they put them in like safe deposit
bags all over the world and like,
it would be extremely
difficult for someone to be
able to actually find each of
these and take the money. So they
have that as a cold storage solution.
And then for their hot wallet solution,
because in exchange must necessarily
have some coins touch the ear in that,
right? So how they do that?
Well, they just insure it, right?
So they actually have Lloyd's of London
that ensures all their hot wallet things
such a, you have that
security in place. Right?
So I think overtime solutions will happen.
They're no key points.
What's diversify the I just
really quick, um, yeah, use,
use it as a bunch of different solutions.
Storage and harbor wallets tends to
be the same as I use the ledger nano,
personally. Yeah. Just really quick.
Yeah. Thank you, Ben. That simmer
[inaudible].